jour d'examen du code de la route à la
plateforme industrielle courrier de La
Poste à Bois d'Arcy les deux
examinatrices préparent les preuve après
avoir suivi une formation le 19 et 20
juin dernier Marie lor cumule son poste
de contrôle de la qualité du service et
cette nouvelle fonction j'ai trouvé que
c'était une une opportunité pour la
poste pour donner une nouvelle image de
la poste après la constitution du
dossier dans une auto-école ou à la
préfecture les candidats s'inscrivent
sur le site internet de La Poste coup
d'inscription versé à l'entreprise
publique ils reçoivent ensuite une
convocation par
mail après un premier échec Abdel passe
son code pour la première fois avec la
nouvelle version l'examen se déroule
individuellement sur tablette avec des
questions différentes pour chaque
candidat les réponses sont envoyées au
ministère de
l'intérieur c'est le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui procède à la correction
ensuite une fois bah que la correction
est faite les candidats reçoivent sous
48 he hors jour férier et weekend leur
résultat par mail venu accompagner son
ami Abdel Ousman a déjà son code en
poche je l'ai passé à serg Pontoise j'ai
dû attendre pas mal de temps pour avoir
une date alors que mon ami il a passé
très très rapidement la poste il y a
plus de dates c'est moins long après une
heure d'épreuve l'examen est terminé
pour Abdel franchement je pr les
tablettes c'est plutôt mieux parce que
on a plus l'image devant nous
ouais c'est plutôt mieux que que sur les
boîtiers en septembre prochain un
nouveau centre d'examen devrait ouvrir
dans une autre plateforme industriel
courrier
yvelinoise